you mentioned the the cia the domestic
terror stuff because we have this actual
big story from cnn canada will list the
proud boys movement as a terrorist
group that's that's the just the story
canada is now saying the proud boys are
terrorists
they say they'll be deemed an
ideologically motivated violent
extremist group along with three others
adam waffen the base
and the russian imperial movement of
which the proud boys don't necessarily
belong in that group at all
the government said in a news release
their violent actions and rhetoric
are fueled by white supremacy
anti-semitism racism homophobia
islamophobia and misogyny and
unfortunately
often in combination of all of the above
said public safety minister bill blair
at a news conference wednesday
i mean it's just factually incorrect
because as everyone else i ricky taro
was not a white man
when asked about the new terrorist
designation of the proud boys uh
for the proud voice blair said that the
events of january 6 at the u.s capitol
did initiate a political response in
canada
but that the decision was not political
quote and as a disturbing and concerning
as those images of those events were
they also provided law enforcement and
our intelligence services with a trove
of new information
in which quite frankly many of these
groups revealed themselves
said blair adding that canada's decision
was based on evidence intelligence and
law
my understanding proud boys don't really
operate all that much in canada
isn't that true i mean i haven't seen
anything i asked my audience today like
what did the proud
proud boys do in canada i mean i haven't
seen any protest i haven't seen any
attacks i haven't seen any actions or
consequences that have
led to any kind of human suffering and
now the out that the article mentions
three groups
the proud boys are now listed also with
al qaeda
the muhahajin and isis so
that's the designation that they give
the boys and you know whatever you think
about them like them or hate them
i think this is a stretch to say the
least and it's a very slippery slope
because they're essentially saying that
anyone could be a terrorist in the
future let's talk about what happens
next
uh i'm not going to name any specific
banks but there are many banks that are
international banks
they operate in united states they're
very large some of the biggest in the
country and they operate in canada as
well
believe it or not though you know for a
lot of people who haven't traveled there
are a bunch of really crazy other comp
you know you got another country and
you'll see a bunch of different banks
you never heard of and that's okay i
mean it should be obvious but a lot of
people are kind of surprised
to see a bunch of weird banks i never
heard of but in this current day and age
it's really interesting to see a lot of
these banks the same banks exist in a
bunch of other countries
let's say you've got some guy who's a
proud boy in the united states
never been to a rally never been to an
event never been in a fight
his bank calls him up and says although
in the united states you have a right to
free speech
and you have never been convicted of a
crime or charge of the crime or even at
a rally
in canada you are deemed a terrorist and
we operate in canada so we cannot
provide financial services to you
lest the canadian government come after
us so now if there is a company that
requires
any kind of government certification or
permitting through canada for their
canadian arm they will come for you in
the united states
there are probably web services
especially that say well we operate in
canada as well like facebook for
instance
what happens now well canada's going to
say we want you to ban all the
terrorists
you cannot have facebook in our country
if you host terrorism
well now that the proud boys are
terrorists facebook will be like okay
what do we do do we ban them all and
then make it so that they're only banned
in canada
so when they post things doesn't appear
in canada or does facebook just start
banning them outright
i'm pretty sure for the most part
they've all been banned anyway
but now we're going to start seeing how
in the us you may have rights
but thanks to the ever expanding
international corporate
system and international free trade
stuff
you could you can get some small island
nation with a decent amount of money
and they could say whatever they want
and then these big corporations if it
fits their fits the bill they're going
to be like okay cool ban them get rid of
them they're done
so yeah sure you'll be allowed to uh you
know live and function as you want but
what about visa and mastercard
visa and mastercard operate in canada
what if canada says to them
you are providing financial services for
a terrorist organization so then visa
and mastercard in the united states tell
the proud boys anybody's ever been
associated
we're shutting you off from all credit
card services
that's that's that's it there's two
companies maybe go discover amex i guess
but what happens when those companies
say the same thing because they operate
internationally as well
this designation is insane and we're
gonna start seeing just how bad this
whole domestic war on terror is gonna
get
the babies are gonna get thrown out with
the bathwater here i mean it's also
important to remember like if you
read the front page of the washington
post the last couple days
it reads the the copy reads as if there
was
a planned premeditated like domestic
terror attack a revolutionary attack
that was planned
and implemented and was successful and
people are dead so that this is what
they really and
truly believe in the minds of people
like aoc
there was a bunch of six foot five super
ripped dudes with night vision goggles
and
tactical gear storming in going move
move move now pull us his office run run
and then a bunch of cops came in and
fought him and it was this great battle
and then she's hiding in the bathroom
and the guy bangs with her boom boom
where is she and then she's like what's
happening
it's a cop and he goes get her out of
here and she's like oh no
no and that's that's how they're framing
it when in reality it was a bunch of
like bewildered bumbling fools and the
cops opened the door
at one part there was the storming of
the central door but the cops opened the
door and people are waving little flags
and walking in
and the cops are like oh that's your
right to protest one cop took a selfie
with people
in reality there was also individuals
that had
jackets with their phone numbers on the
back because of it
it was representing a construction
company that they had and i'm sorry
you know a lot of these masculist people
they're they're not criminal masterminds
uh they're they're not the sharpest
knights in the draw especially when they
have their phone number on the back of
their jacket
doing all of them or when the guy takes
the podium and then he smiles and waves
to the camera there's there's no plan
here but we we all know this but the
washington post puts it on the front
page that there was a battle in the
capital and people are dead and it was
because we have terrorists in america so
if you take that as the base which is
now history
right i tweet i tweeted a poll today i
said who won the battle of narratives
for january 6th
the commies are the good guys 80 90
the commies even our guys believe right
that they that we lost the battle of the
narrative for january 6
which is going to go down for all of
history which is now going to be the
linchpin
in the patriot act stuff and the in the
insurgents crackdown that's coming
and there's going to be a lot of
collateral damage and you know what
people aren't going to care
we have collateral damage obama obama
drops bombs on babies to get a terrorist
and guess what people say
collateral damage collateral damage i
don't think that the
that's too far away from where we are
here and i'm talking to
john robb uh next week who is an amazing
strategist technologist
he writes at the intersection of war and
politics and technology
he's been predicting this for some time
he's been predicting the fact
that there's going to be a corporate
techno fascism
rallying around an insurgency counter
insurgency development in the united
states
to just use that as the tool in the
vehicle by which just clamp down
on free speech human rights freedom
association freedom of movement
all of the things that we hold dear as
americans so really if you think about
it
they're framing us as insurgents you
know us
maga right term right side people it
it's it's kind of true
because we're occupied we're occupied by
people that don't believe
in the american spirit they don't
believe in american history they want to
change american history they don't care
about any of it
what does second amendment say right to
bear arms shall not be infringed
bear is it bear yeah keep it okay keep
and bear arms yeah
what does it mean to bear arms open
carry
and in how many states are you not
allowed to open so many of course
right yeah it's just the constitution is
completely meaningless it's gone i know
it's gone and it's going to get even
worse it's going to get even worse
and so you know what i'm looking forward
to though for the first time to see a
third amendment lawsuit
oh man what's that you got you got me on
the third one
no quartering in private homes of
military that one's never going to
happen
it's just archaic and it's really
interesting that it was a big deal back
then and it's not really been that big
of a deal for us in modern times
but all the rest of them especially the
fourth the fifth the first second
they're all huge even the ninth the
tenth i mean almost every amendment
i didn't even remember the third when
you brought it up just i was like wait
which one
yep i love it yeah yeah the soldiers
can't be courted in private homes
yeah i could see like if there was an
uprising an armed uprising and then the
people that were uprising would be like
we need to use your house we need to we
need to use your house and that could be
like a violation of people
that was basically what it was you know
back in the day the soldiers would be
like
we're fighting a war and so the soldiers
are coming in and we need a place to
stay so we're taking your home
not that the government would do it but
that our own people that were rising up
to protect us from the government would
try and do it
but these are these are pretty scary
times because we have thousands of
troops inside of the u.s capitol we have
politicians we have the mainstream media
cheering on
the deep state arm of the intelligence
agencies large unaccountable departments
within our government
that are going after people for their
speech for their beliefs and they're
doing it more and more aggressively as
we just learned that the fbi
raided the house of rally organizers
that organized a rally on the night
before january 6. now cnn was
you know wrote a whole article about
this how this was justified because of
their
language but again these people weren't
charged
they just had their doors busted down
because they organized a political
rally now i don't know exactly what
these individuals said i don't even know
who they are
but but this is again an fbi that has
been mobilized
and activated and is becoming more and
more political
when it came to individuals like epstein
they sat on their hands they didn't do
anything for over 30
years 30 years so many horrible crimes
are happening with that individual
nothing but now
you know we have this insurrection
they're mobilized they're activated
they're putting up wanted posters all
over the united states oh my god
in every bus shelter in dc it's just all
these pictures of guys in maga hats and
just like do you know these people
all up and down my neighborhood all over
the place you know an additional scary
element to what's happening is not only
are they looking to prosecute people for
crimes today
not only are they looking probably into
the future to prosecute people for
anticipated crimes
they're going back five years they're
going back ricky going back five years
to ricky vaughn to get the guy for a
meme now
it it it's possible that it was actually
illegal and you can't tell people the
wrong way to vote and whatever but it
was it was pretty bad what he did uh so
he so this guy
uh he was you know like an s poster i
guess you want to call it an ish poster
and he had this it was it was a viral
meme that was going around that said
i i don't necessarily think it's even
fair to call it a meme for the most part
i know a lot of people on the right have
said that
it was like vote you know vote early and
vote by text text this number
avoid the lines yeah avoid the lines
text this number and it said
paid for by political candidate
so-and-so or whatever so it was like
you can call it you can say it was a
joke and you go back i'm going to share
this
so i don't think the guy deserves to go
to prison for it well if he was trying
to trick people into thinking that
they'd voted that's pretty nasty federal
absolutely yeah it's crime yep and it
said that was paid for by the candidate
and that's
that's hard to believe trump didn't
prosecute the guy so now five years
later
now michael hold on there's a bunch of
people who did the same thing on the
other side
identica there's a viral video of a
woman putting on a hat and saying trump
supporters go you know go here to vote
it was like totally fake
so the issue is trump didn't prosecute
any of those people now that
democrats are in power they're going
after the people who went after them but
not the people did the same thing
so the scariest thing is going to be the
score settling
right yeah they're going to want to
settle the score
and that means that a lot of people who
thought that they were safe and a lot of
people who thought that they'd
gotten away with it may not oh they
didn't no i mean it's going to get it's
going to be
it's going to be chaos look we've got
permanent
barbed wire fencing around the capitol
right now the washington dc is currently
under occupation
it is occupied by the national guard and
i'm not saying that to be bombastic
literally five thousand national guard
will be permanently placed there so
i'm sorry they're saying the green zone
will be permanent i don't know how many
troops will be there
but they're saying at least until march
there's gonna be 5 000 national
guardsmen
you don't think that i mean that is the
central part of the iraqi strategy
the green zone they've established the
green zone they're establishing their
counter-insurgency network
and it's pretty soon we're going to
start seeing quiet bribes for
assassinations in the middle of the
night
and drone strikes i mean i'm
exaggerating a little bit
or am i i don't know how far are they
gonna go people that we know they're
rabid
they don't care about reality they don't
care about the constitution they care
about settling scores
they can't even be happy mike cernovich
the other day was tweeting out he's like
where is the jubilation from the
democrats right yeah they won
do you remember what it was like in
january of 2017. holy crap
that's why i met you was it the
deplorable too yeah like dude the energy
was insane
everybody was ecstatic there's none of
that
there's none of that because they're
negative nasty they're still crying
yes this is the crazy thing when when
trump won
many we saw the memes of these people
dropping their knees and crying and
screaming and mourning
and the trump supporters were like what
they didn't think they were going to win
in the first place so they're laughing
and celebrate good times come on all
that good stuff well joe biden did that
one
at the at the at the uh wasn't the price
the um i can't think of the word the dnc
but
at the convention um when he was
nominated
but after joe biden won
they were still crying yeah and i i
remember seeing like you mentioned
andrew sullivan was like listening to
biden's speech and started crying yeah
and i'm like they're still crying
because they summoned a demon to destroy
their enemy now the demon's president
he's not a literal demon but it's like
when you use something you hate to
destroy something else you hate you're
still gonna end up hating it no but but
but
they like biden what i think happened is
they're infected with
a demoralization mind virus they wanted
trump out they didn't want by hand
let go of the hate and anger because
it's not it wasn't really about trump
it was just they just hate yeah and so
what happens now is they're redirecting
it towards this nebulous concept of
trumpism
which is meaningless they're saying now
they're gonna now they're saying oh
trumpism is the problem and
listen you're you've you've got these
satellites orbiting this planet
trump was that planet that was where all
the media and all the narrative and all
that was orbiting
now the planet's gone there's nothing to
orbit anymore and so they're pointing at
nothing trump so quickly disappeared
from public
the public spotlight no social media
haven't heard a word for the man outside
of these vague statements you get from
the office of 45 emails he's sending out
to people
where it's like here's my response to
impeachment yet they've still repeatedly
done stories
the daily beast this one journalist i'm
not going to say her name
ran a story saying trump lost the
presidency and twitter guess which one
hurt worse and i'm like it's been
two weeks trump it's been longer than
since trump's got suspended from twitter
okay why are you still writing the same
story you wrote a month ago
they were all saying this they're gonna
keep doing it because they just
hate they need something to hate trump
is the avatar of their hate
but he's gone now so they just hate well
they're gonna go after anything and
everything that they can
and to me what you're saying was
definitely exemplified by
an article that i saw from the
independent today that was titled
outrage as alleged capital rioter is
permitted vacation to mexico
ahead of trial and this whole article
was doxing this lady who was
again not convicted of a crime doesn't
have a criminal record
she had a work-related event that she
needed to go to mexico and a judge
said sure you could go to that that's
not true what never happened
what do you mean news story broke uh and
we saw a viral trend on twitter white
privilege
people were saying white privilege is
this capital rioter saying that she
wants to go on vacation and the judge
letting her do it never happened the
judge never issued an order saying she
was allowed to go on vacation ryan
reilly of huffington post issued
an emergency correction saying everybody
everybody it never happened
it was a proposal not an order and the
media didn't fact check so they ran off
and then the independent media ran with
it
and then the independent the independent
ran with it and that's that's the
information that i got from today i
didn't see their correction i talked
about it and i read it i read the full
article today
this is what happens when you trust the
mainstream media luke yeah so you got me
i'm talking red-handed
they they they all ran this story
claiming that you know there was a
one high-profile left-wing commentator
showed a picture of a black man at the
riot who was
denied bail and he says i wonder what
about this man resulted in him getting
denied while this other story is
breaking hmm
well the other story is breaking is fake
news more importantly
this woman is being charged with i think
two misdemeanors disorderly conduct yes
and
entering you know restricted grounds
apparently she didn't even go in the
building
and so she's getting a misdemeanor
charge which i tell you
when if when she goes in there and
they're like did you go on the grounds i
did your honor and were you being
disorderly well i disagree but i accept
the charges no contest your honor is
gonna be like okay
we're gonna give you 20 hours of
community service court supervision have
a nice day that's the end of it she's
going to go home and then they'll forget
forget it ever happened and then
mainstream media is going to freak out
about that and then also have another
rage bait click about this but
the larger point that i was trying to
make here is why is the independent
media the independent concentrating on
this lady
why you know it used to be where the
media used to go up against
special interest he used to go against
the powers that be it used to go up
against
actual people that actually mattered in
your life and had an effect on the way
you lived your life
they don't do that anymore it's it's
this lady that you have to be outraged
about look at look at what happened in
sweden i don't know if you know the
story jack but
uh several years ago you know i went to
sweden for this last time sweden thing
and one of the biggest stories i
discovered was that only a few months
prior
one of their biggest newspapers hacked
discus
which is this commenting system people
use onbase websites
to to docs anonymous commenters
go to their homes and film them knock on
the door when they come out there's a
camera in their face why'd you say this
disparaging comment about you know
immigrants or whatever
some of the comments were innocuous
saying i think sweden needs to take care
of their their citizens and stop
allocating tax funds towards people who
don't live here
and they're like why are you racist
these people got ambushed
the question is why was a newspaper
hacking and doxxing people
and targeting individuals news
organizations are supposed to be
an uh the necessary component of a of a
true
democratic government or true government
of the people they challenge the powers
that be
they write the things that people don't
want to hear instead they write the
thing that the tribalists love to hear
as they burn the witch
it's witch hunts they go after people
for nasty opinions
and they say this woman she walked on
the capitol
now we're seeing like anybody who's even
in dc is being targeted
were you in dc while it was going down
you're done they'll nuke you they'll ban
you they'll fire you'll come after you
there was that that one rapper guy who
got dropped from his label simply for
listening to trump speaking and leaving
there's that one uh army psychological
operations officer who went down in a
bus with some people saw trump speak and
then left and they are getting
they're getting investigated there it's
it's gonna get bad man
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you